and joining me here from sports
illustrated senior rider day after the
nba draft and day before everything
starts going free agency chris mannix
right here on the rich hazard show how
are you chris
i'm good rich how you doing what would
be the story i'm fine thank you
better for talking to you uh what what
is the story of draft night
in your estimation chris well
more inactivity in terms of consummating
deals than i expected
um in the days leading up to the draft
you know there were several teams in the
top ten including minnesota number one
that were shopping their picks and
you know some of the activity took place
prior to the draft i mean there were big
moves made by oklahoma city there were
big moves made
by new orleans that that shook up the
draft a little bit but
i was a little surprised at the lack of
activity
inside that top ten it's like i mean
it's tough to declare
winners and losers on players that
haven't played an nba minute yet but
um i i was a little surprised that we
didn't see
more activity inside that top ten okay
and then the top five did anything
surprise you there or that pretty much
went chalk
the way that you were expecting it went
close to chalk
uh you could have seen some shake up at
that four or five slot
um you know obi topping going to the
knicks i thought he might have gone
a little bit higher uh the israeli kid i
thought he might have gone
a little bit higher but nothing shocking
i mean there are certainly some
intriguing
you know possibilities now and i think
the guys in that top three
are going to be inextricably linked
because there really wasn't a consensus
number one
in this draft i mean anthony edwards is
a very good prospect but
you would find plenty of people across
the league that would have taken james
wiseman
in that spot he is an incredible
athletic specimen who i think is going
to be a really good uh
modern five in today's nba and lamella
ball might have the most upside i mean
he is
a dynamic playmaker i mean he's got some
problems with defense his shot and god
knows what his father brings to the
table
in charlotte but i mean he is he's the
goods
as as a play-making point guard and you
know for a charlotte team that badly
needs star power
um you know that's uh that that's a
pretty good pickup well
chris mannix here on the rich eisen show
and the the wiseman picked this was
supposed to be
uh a crowning moment for uh all the
heartache and pain that golden state
went through last year to earn
the second overall pick and then add
somebody of this kid's talent
um and it is turned out to be wiseman to
the mix of
steph draymond and clay and then earlier
in the day clay
uh seems to suffer a significant injury
uh to his achilles what can you tell me
about that and how this all
played out with the warriors yesterday
chris yeah he's gonna have
an mri today in southern california
that will you know speak to what of the
significance of the injury
in in talking to some people close to
the situation
i don't want to say there's pessimism
but there's a sense of dread
when it comes to this it's a lower leg
injury not to the same leg that he had
the acl injury
a year ago but a lower leg injury that
for what i was told he had difficulty
putting pressure on
as he walked off the floor and that just
these are kind of telltale signs rich
about something that
that could be significant so nothing
will be known until after the mri today
but
there is a strong sense of dread in
golden state about
uh the immediate future of klay thompson
chris mannix here
on the rich eisen show then let's get to
what went down with the bucks this week
giving up what they gave up for for a
holiday
and then bogdanovic um being acquired
and then not
because he doesn't want to come and all
of this
in i guess one would say hopes of
making sure giannis understands they
hear him or they're setting the table
or have they gotten some sort of
assurance from him what is going on
with the milwaukee bucks chris well i i
think john horace the gm there
is doing exactly what you do in this
situation
you push all your chips onto the table
to show giannis
that your only goal is to make that team
championship caliber around him they get
true holiday
who i think is a a reasonable upgrade
over eric bledsoe who defends at a high
level
makes shots i mean he's he might be i've
heard kevin durant say this he might be
the best defender
at the guard position in the league so
you add a high level player to the mix
the bogdanovic situation is weird
because
i was told yesterday that boganovic does
want to play in milwaukee
i'm not entirely sure why this is
playing out the way it is i mean there's
a theory that
you know the deal that was constructed
might not have met nba approval but
dynavic is restricted for agent and
there are some
not to get too deep in the weeds but
some salary machinations that
were a little bit tricky in putting that
deal together
so it could be rich something as simple
as
bogdanovic gets to restricted for agency
and a new
form of the deal is constructed and that
sends bogdanovic
to milwaukee i and if that happens it's
an
a off season for the bucks i mean i
don't know
that that giannis definitely signed that
super max
you know now that once these deals are
are constructed but
this sends a powerful message i mean but
donovak is a very good player i mean
nobody watches sacramento kings games
but this is a guy
that can really play he's a playmaking
shooting you know high level
international guard i mean he he's going
to be an immediate upgrade
to what they do uh either with the
second unit or in the starting lineup so
i i
i think they've made that team
measurably better and more importantly
that's a team that's measurably better
for postseason play they've got shooters
they've got playmakers uh that's
something that was sorely lacking in
that second round loss to miami so all
these machinations by milwaukee have
been done
as a signal i i just find it you know
hard to believe that they would make all
these maneuvers without
some assurance from giannis that if you
do a and b
i'm i'm here or i'm already in you know
what i'm saying like what what what
what is the status of that and what is
the timing on all of that
chris well giannis dating back to his
meeting with ownership
after the bucks lost in the bubble um
has not given them any indication that
he wants to play anywhere else
now that's not the same as saying i'm
ready to sign
a super max extension with that team but
he has not expressed
kind of the anthony davis-like desire to
go elsewhere
and while i don't think that the bucks
have gotten any assurances from yaz
it'll sign uh
right now and look there may be reason
to play this out you know
into next summer for giannis whether
it's financial or or otherwise
uh but i think milwaukee feels and in
fact i know milwaukee feels
that if they keep making moves to
upgrade this team
giannis is going to want to stay i mean
they've done they've done a lot for
giannis
in milwaukee i mean they've built that
team around him they added his brother
to the team i mean that matters
to giannis i mean i was in the bubble
for a couple of months rich and those
two were inseparable
in that bubble in fact the other brother
with the lakers they were hanging out
the entire time so
that matters to a guy like giannis so i
think what the bucks are hoping
is that what they've done this offseason
tells giannis that they are
they're built to win right now and and
being in milwaukee will offer him the
best chance to win chris maddox few
minutes left with the sports illustrated
senior rider day after the nba draft and
so 6 p.m friday is when the free agency
new league gear
window opens up correct that's the next
step right now yes that's
uh yeah that's the next one all right
now um
who's the first to go here what's what
what do we expect just over the horizon
now
now that everything's jam-packed and
compacted drafted
it's not it's going to be frantic that's
for sure right i mean
this has all been been wild it's not the
most robust free agent market
you know this you know next summer is
the summer people are targeting largely
because
at least for now giannis is scheduled to
be a part of it and there are
a number of teams that are trying to
keep their powder dry for that summer so
they can have some flexibility miami
being
chief among them um one of the more
intriguing players
on the markets probably fred van vliet
from toronto i mean he had is coming off
another
great season with the raptors won a
championship there will be a market
maybe in detroit
or new york for him the raptors want to
bring him back but that's a 20 million
dollar per year salary
uh that you're talking about and you've
got to be sure that fred van bleet is
your guy but he's probably
i would say the most intriguing name on
the free agent market everything else
rich
is tied to the trade market and what
exactly the houston rockets decide to do
in the next few weeks or even a few
months with james harden i mean that
that is that's the guy i mean everyone
from brooklyn to maybe even golden state
to some others are going to be
angling to be in the james harden
sweepstakes if the rockets
really start to push him on the open
market and you know they're the team
that could
reshape the nba with some of the deals
that they make that was my next question
is what's going on there because you
know uh hardin
has said he wants to go to the nets uh
according to all reports and
usually what a star player wants a star
player gets and he's a star player
the warriors in the mix is that is that
in response to clay
or i mean where did where did that one
come from
chris well i mean i kind of talked about
this a year ago when
you know the rockets had you know we're
kind of it plateaued a little bit you
know the
season didn't end uh with chris paul the
way they wanted to
and the warriors because of that draft
pick and because they have a very
lightly protected first round pick from
minnesota
next year they're a player for any team
that's looking to get a haul of assets
and while they don't have the blue chip
player to offer like say if brooklyn
does if you can get
you know james wiseman who is
potentially a superstar
you can get that draft pick and you want
to take on andrew wiggins who
you know is still a decent player albeit
an overpaid one
they can be in play and look one thing
that's obvious about james hart that's
what i tried to tell people a year ago
like james harden is an alpha in houston
but he's far more concerned about
winning at this stage of his career
than he is being the scoring champion
for the fourth year in a row i mean he's
he's accomplished a lot individually and
now as he hits his early 30s
from what i'm always told he's looking
to win that's why he's willing to go to
brooklyn
and sacrifice to play alongside kevin
durant and kyrie irving i think he blew
into other places
like at golden state and sacrifice uh to
play alongside
star players he's looking for an
opportunity to win and and there's only
a handful of teams that can really offer
what about lastly i guess um the team
that i
i mentioned quite a bit at the top of
the show because i thought they had a
dynamic night and i loved daryl mori i
mean what a night he had last night
um what about that idea you know i'm
i'm reading in uh philadelphia inquirer
that meek mill
is reaching out to hardin to say why
don't you come here but
wouldn't that blow everything up uh the
way that things are kind of set up for
maury i mean
what what about that possibility well
daryl moore loves james harden yeah
there's no doubt about that
and philadelphia is one of the possible
destinations for harden if
the rockets get aggressive which to be
clear right now
they're in they're not in any rush nor
should they be i mean harden
has two guaranteed years left of his
contract a third option that's worth
like 50 million dollars so
you know he's tied into the rockets one
way or the other so houston
rightfully their position right now is
you know what's the rush we want
if we do decide to deal james harden we
want a bidding war and that bidding war
might not materialize
until mid-season when teams start to
figure out what they are and what they
need and they want some desperate teams
out there
uh to make a run at a guy like harden
philadelphia's interesting but
philadelphia
to get hardened you'd have to throw in
ben simmons it's as simple as that
like it's uh you know you don't get
james harden without including ben
simmons and like i'm not saying that's
not something that the sixers would do
uh i certainly i think would be
uh uh something worth considering but
it's
i i don't think they're there yet
i don't think they're the strongest team
in the hunt for james harden unless
they're willing to put all their chips
in with draft picks
and young players to go get hardened
because other teams like brooklyn
and like some others can be willing to
do that so i guess with free agency
beginning this weekend
we're not expected to see anything
giannis harden or westbrook related
this weekend that's not uh on the
immediate horizon
essentially well we're saying giannis
giannis is unpredictable we don't know
what giannis is going to do and what
milwaukee's moves mean to him
uh he's very hard to read on that count
uh hard and i would not expect anything
to happen westbrook
there's just no market for westbrook
rich like there's like you know
the knicks i mean they they used to be
this dumb
but i don't think they're this dumb
anymore like they're they i just don't i
don't look i've got no sense from
talking to people in new york but
they're interested
or at least are prioritizing uh russell
westbrook at this point they're trying
to rebuild organically they had a pretty
good night
in the draft um they're trying to do
things in a more methodical
traditional way charlotte i thought was
a possibility before
westbrook is represented by jordan brand
it made some sense for him to play with
the hornets but
i don't get the sense that now that
lamellar ball is part of the mix that
russell
is going to be on the table there and
after that you know
unless you're looking to salary dump in
which the rockets are not
it's tough to find a taker i mean
miami's not going to do it because
they're
again trying to keep their powder dry
for 2021
and there's only limited number of teams
able to take on that salary so
i i it's going to be difficult to say
the least for the rockets to trade
russell westbrook he is a a tough guy to
move at this stage of his career yeah
and the lakers uh
basically just sat back watched it all
play out and
anthony davis will just re-sign there i
imagine and that's that's the next step
i mean yeah obviously yeah i think david
davis is is a foregone conclusion right
at this point i mean
it would be kind of funny if he you know
kick the tires on chicago because he's
from there but i doubt it i think he's
i think he's a lock to sign a max level
extension i love the dennis schroeder
move i mean rob polenka's had a hell of
a year you know with some of the moves
he made last year
to get that team in position now you
deal danny green for a 27 year old you
know
top level guard who is coming off his
best nba season that was
a very good move for the lakers they
weren't going to get anything of that
value with the 28th pick
uh green was okay but obviously
struggled some in the playoffs
i think schroeder makes them better
that's scary for every team out there
yeah and then of course green winds up
in philadelphia by the end of last night
with al horford
um and his big huge contract showing up
in oklahoma city i mean
it's amazing it's been a wild week man a
wild 72 hours
no doubt about that well they'll i mean
i'll tell you this much like
oklahoma city i mean at some point we're
going to get to like 2025
and we're gonna have oklahoma city and
and new orleans the only teams picking
they're gonna have all the drafts in
that that year but i i look
i promise you this rich yes they'll turn
al horford to a first round pick down
the line they will
again they have been able to take
advantage of desperate teams
you know last year the clippers were
desperate the rockets needed to move
chris paul
they were desperate the uh the sun seems
to make a move for chris paul they were
maybe not desperate they wanted him so
you know there they'll find a team that
wants al horford by mid-season they'll
get something real back in return
you're awesome chris thanks for the time
appreciate i know you're busy last night
busy today appreciate the call
anytime rich the man chris mannix si
chrismanics on both
twitter and instagram right here on the
rich eisen show